hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
no I'm John Humphrey are gonna watch I
love so many k-pop groups you do like
like who black pink txt yes other k-pop
groups yes I went to Koreatown the other
day that was cool
BTS BTS DNA official music video at our
patreon we do weekly Q&A and TV show
reaction stream alongs but john three
times a week does music video coverage
reactions because 99.99% of the time
when we put up a reaction to a music
video on youtube you'll often find that
people cut up their music videos for one
of two reasons includes copyrighted
content or blocked worldwide which is
usually the case so we have to cut them
up that way you know it can be visible
on YouTube for sure and today comes from
the one and only
Natalie Doran I love you my dear I call
you baby when I go to sleep but only to
yourself it's weird and I've heard it
down the hall so many times
[Music]
universe we're all connected
whoa can I camera is this steady yeah
yeah yeah yeah I know why everyone's in
love with it every time I see them
[Music]
it's not gonna make
[Music]
so the television
[Music]
I want baby
it's all Phaedra
[Music]
they're 1,000 team
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
- I love the camera angles in this
and colors too
[Music]
give me a little better
one of these heads look at my wedding
song
[Music]
Kosmic
that's an Apple desktop
these guys are insecure about anything
no they trained that out of you too
young Wow
[Music]
steered
we're all since the inception of the
universe we're meant to be together this
is like episode of citizen
your money your money
[Music]
is wait I'm gonna learn one of these
dance routines
[Music]
start energy pop new movement
I have some deep thoughts I'm gonna
share with you guys after this blood
spatter expert come in and be like yeah
clearly this guy shot himself is half
waiting for Breaking Bad logos to appear
although yeah yeah yeah one of their
songs will be based off the sample
that's the Breaking Bad theme music is
that oh I think I think therefore you
are if I were to try to examine the
lyrics here I think what he's trying to
communicate is that they're meant to be
together
yeah yeah I think so whoever he's
talking to I think it's about fate yeah
and destiny the love is cosmic it's game
on high but it's also deep within our
DNA I think I think maybe I don't know I
might be reading too much into this
whatever is on point I don't get where
you're going I might need to look up
like the meaning of the lyrics here but
I'm pretty sure that's what it's about
this is an accurate scientific breakdown
of human genetics all right what if he's
not talking what if all these songs
where we think they're talking to like
us us a girl or a boy mm-hmm what if
they not a boy a man especially now okay
you could say a girl and you could be
referencing what if this whole time
they're just talking about each other oh
that would act would it be kind of her
through just love songs for you know
like when a guy in a girl would do like
duets to one another that's like what if
on what if this is the all these guys
just talking to each other
oh those were the DNA were meant to be
together guys
guys were just such best friends let's
form a band and sing about how yeah
that's
and so many of their videos at least the
ones that I've seen include passages
where they're just kickin it together
and like having fun yeah so this would
end those are some of the most
heartwarming first of the videos
honestly like are they are they all
pursuing the same individual and they're
all singing to that one person or that
they all have different significant
others in that are just singing to that
person you give you might think it's
weird go to this three guys think about
just one girl girl no they're all dated
they're in a polyamorous relationship
with one person altogether they need to
make it clear to me on a serious note
what I thought was really cool about
this I think when I look at the lyrics
I'm like okay yeah I get it it's a fate
since the inception of the universe and
everything to get like it's all of that
but I think I'm a big believer in stuff
like Law of Attraction should I be more
aware of the power of Law of Attraction
and make an active effort to apply it
more into my life on a conscious level
to attract more of what I want yes yes I
should because I often forget but a big
part of Law of Attraction
and energy is that we are all connected
in our blood cells and our DNA to the
universe that's what makes it's all
connected that we're all connected on an
energy cellular level
so I actually thought in terms of a
visual medium that this was pretty cool
because you're getting a lot of like
chemistry science cosmic it's like you
saw off with the inception of the
universe here through the eyeball
through the DNA and then and so from
that perspective from that point in
terms of the visuals I'm not really
communicated here in the lyric so in
terms of the visuals I really thought
that was a neat thing to do here because
you do scientific breakdown but you're
also showing that the essence from
everywhere from Universal and blood we
are connected and we're meant to be
together yeah yeah one for a BTS video I
thought this was also actually kind of
unified in a sense because it very much
takes that theme from the song and
enhances it visually yeah whereas a lot
of their videos are very dense with
these laced and woven plot threads and
symbols and stuff like that I lace a lot
of things you
I later wake up but yeah like I'm used
to BTS videos that are very onion like
in the way that you can kind of peel
back the layers and flying dragon yeah
and this one is kind of refreshing Lee
yeah contained because it's pretty
simple in the sense that we just got a
whole bunch of vibrant colors a lot of
really great dance moves obviously and
these thematic elements of DNA and the
universe and some you know things that
look like vectors and math and stuff
like that and just as a different
dimension of their visual expression I
appreciated this plus the colors are a
different palette than at least a lot of
the videos I've seen they're very bright
and royal a lot of the time and even
like in the costuming like I love the
way that they mix and match with the
different colors like the teals and the
reds that tie them all together and
stuff like that like this felt like a
little bit more of a laid-back fun music
video for them but I had a great time
lay back and deed I mean as laid-back as
BTS gonna be it's gonna be like laser
accurate dancing either way but in terms
of yeah it's not like one member is the
protagonist and everybody else is a
projection of his personality in a
different content you know like this is
a very contained video for them you know
John yeah I got it bouncing off your
point mm-hmm you said like elements of
vector and I do zeroing in on that one
epic word I will agree I think this
musical ear has a there's a quantity
that has direction as well as magnitude
especially especially as determining the
position of one point in space relative
to another compared with like a scalar
scholar a scalar uh-huh you know which
mean it's like having only magnitude not
Direction you know what I mean totally
honestly I had no idea
we're written on the back of a math test
and so some of that [ __ ] crept its way
into the music video big fan of math and
physics so this is the music for you
everything off of the love yourself her
album has a very intellectual physics
based
Lance so if you want to learn something
while you dance your cares away and
express the love that's deep within your
heart a pick up that album in well well
guys guys Natalie Doran thank you so
much for requesting this my beautiful
beautiful woman here what can I say
other than the fact that you said you
went to the hospital recently and you're
refusing to tell me what for don't you
understand that you and I are connected
on a vector scale that you and I should
always be open and honest with each
other because if you're sick I'm sick do
you understand if you're in the hospital
I am in the hospital with you cuz we're
connected better at a cosmic loud a Dark
Phoenix level we're like sci-fi twins
you know where if you get punched
I feel the punch too so does this mean
that that next month or in a month or
two you're going to be cosmically
witnessing a BTS show in London with
Natalie yes well I'm jealous of you cuz
I ain't got a connection to nobody on a
cosmic level so you know you're over
here laying up sick and then getting the
benefit of watching BTS live and I'm
over here going what gives all I got is
these music videos I mean thanks Natalie
but I don't feel like this is a strong
of a connection I'm feeling a little
left out I'm feeling this is some fake
love that I'm getting from you all right
I need you Natalie prologue on stage
Josh yeah we got a we got a vector this
we got a vector olive like some matrix
with one row or one column Gabi gotta do
this
give me some grids maybe an axis X Y Z
if you want to get cubic on me whatever
man let's do some this is too long of a
shout-out yep you're not worthy to have
this much of a shout-out sure you want
to scratch that you're more than worthy
boom subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell to get
notified every time a reviewer videos
out and join us on patreon for more
reactions like this one